the power of the default option the fact
that they went from removing the tiny
cups to only giving large and bucket
sized cups for yogurt encourage people
to use more yogurt themselves and they
do that because it looks silly in
comparison and so whenever there's a
possibility that you can set the default
where someone would be encouraged by
implication to use more just like the
fast food upgrade of like do you want
medium or I'm assuming you want to meet
them or hey I'm assuming you want a 32
ounce when you give the default option
many people just like organ donors it
went from I think it was like 10 or 15
of people opting into being an organ
donor to getting 80 of people to become
organ donors by simply saying you not
want to be an organ donor versus do you
want to be an organ owner so if you have
the potential to get seven times more
people to say yes to something just
imply that that's what everyone else is
doing and you can do that through his
default options which is one of the most
powerful psychological selling Tools in
existence and no one even knows it's
happening to them most of the time